ich glaube dass der Skisport ganz
interessant ist Körper und Geist muss da
einfach wirklich am Punkt Dose und es
ist glaube ich richtig gut zum
Abschalten und zu in sehr eigene Welt
zum Eintreten darum glaube das ist ja
ganz guter Ausgleich ist im Alltag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
des österreichischen Bundesheers heute
zu Gast der Zugführer Alexander schmierl
Sportschütze das österreichischen
Bundesheers herzlich willkommen hallo
danke
erfolgreich du bist vor allem ein paar
Wochen zurückgekommen von der
Weltmeisterschaft und hast deine erste
Medaille über der Weltmeisterschaft
geschafft in Kairo im 300 Meter liegend
soweit ich das jetzt richtig hier stehen
habe erklär uns mal was ist der Legend
Bewerb und was bedeutet dir diese erste
Medaille im Einzel deiner
Weltmeisterschaft also ich war sehr sehr
glücklich über die erste einzelne
Medaille jetzt bei der Weltmeisterschaft
habe aber sehr schwieriges ist also
schwierigen Situation statt und da die
letzte Saison haben wir sehr Schwader
noch eine langjährigen Corona
nochwirkung sehr glücklich dass es dann
dort auf den Punkt gebracht habe
und da liegend Bewerb schon so aus also
wir haben da einen Riemen zu Fixierung
und da ist es quer eingespannt sozusagen
und da geht es um die höchste Präzision
und Fehler Vermeidung also im Liegen
Bewerb wird sehr sehr hoch geschossen an
neuen ist praktisch verboten zu schießen
und es kommt darauf immer die zehn zu
treffen das ist dir auf jeden Fall gut
gelungen äh nicht nur im Einzel sondern
auch im Team auf seine Medaille gemacht
das heißt es schaut so aus als wären wir
allgemein derzeit im Schützen Sport ist
sehr erfolgreich oder wir sagen haben
sehr erfolgreiche Weltmeisterschaften
gehabt damals sehr zufrieden glaube ich
es hätte im olympischen Bereich noch ein
bisschen besser laufen können dass man
da vielleicht nur den ein oder anderen
guten Platz dazu reden hätten keiner
aber grundsätzlich muss man sagen haben
wir sechs Medaille und Dokument glaube
ich ganz zufrieden sein das gemeint dann
ist es so war eher schwierig wie wirkt
sich eine schwierige Situation bei
Schützen aus bei mir im Schwimmbad ist
oder sich einfach eine Zeiten nicht
schaffe meine Trainings nicht mehr mit
der Qualität mit dem Niveau hinbekommen
kann man sich das beim Schießen
vorstellen wie wie sieht man das wie
merkt man das ja also wir haben heute
nicht die Zeiten wo es davor kommt
sondern die Resultate und da war sie
einfach dann in jeder Position schwierig
das perfekte Körpergefühl zum finden ist
Material war eine perfekt abgestimmt und
dann summiert sich das und dann ist man
halt einfach nicht mehr wird Klasse
sondern nur gut ja und das ist halt dann
einfach schon zu wenig her wie schnell
spürt man das also kann man dann einen
Wettkampf haben wo man sagt okay gut das
war jetzt vom Resultat irgendwie zehn
Plätze unter dem was ich erwartet habe
und wenn sich das drei vier Mal
wiederholt dann merkt man langsam okay
irgendwie passt das nicht oder spürt man
das sofort das dass man da jetzt die
Form nicht nicht hatte also man spürt
einem Training das nicht so optimal
läuft ich bin jetzt schon mittlerweile
eigentlich sehr erfahren und komme
darauf mit der Routine sehr gut drüber
retten und die die Wettkämpfe dann noch
ähm etwas retten sozusagen ja aber es
war dann wirklich im letzten Jahr schon
noch
der kronen-infektionen ein bisschen
schwierigen Körpergefühle ob da immer so
so Art Mikrovibrationen gehabt im Körper
und das macht es natürlich für die
absolute Präzision beim Schießen dann
fast
unmöglich da immer perfekte Zehen zu
treffen und das habe ich sehr lange
nachgespürt und erst so im Dezember
jänner ist dann wirklich wieder das
Gefühl Kummer im Training okay jetzt
geht es in die richtige Richtung der
Körper was was sonst tun hat und jetzt
funktioniert das Ganze langsam wieder
und dann musstest du wahrscheinlich erst
wieder aufholen und aufbauen das was
halt vorher mit der Nachwirkungen eher
nicht ging kann ich mir das so
vorstellen ja genau und dann haben wir
schon zu Beginn des Jahres im Jänner die
erste Vorqualifikationen gehabt für für
Weltcups und da ist noch nicht optimal
gelaufen und dann habe ich heute die
ersten zwei drei Weltcups das ist so ein
zuschauen müssen und war sozusagen ein
bisschen auf der Ersatzbank und habe mir
dann in die Saison zurück kämpft und das
eben höchste erfolgreich wenn du jetzt
die vergangenen Weltmeister leichten
anschaust deine Formkurve über die
letzten Jahre und was für ein olympische
spielen in Rio mit dabei du hast schon
mehrere Weltcup Medaillen wie würdest du
deine Entwicklung beschreiben
grundsätzlich ist die Entwicklung sehr
zufriedenstellend für mich also sie geht
laufend nach oben war bis 2019
eigentlich stets aufsteigend und dann
ist eben der ganze Corona wahnsinn da
ausgebrochen auf der Welt und
da habe dann ein knickt gehabt
eigentlich in meiner Karriere in meiner
Laufbahn und habe da wirklich eigentlich
ganz über 21 nicht wirklich gute
Leistungen bringen und habe meine heuer
dann rebellieren können ob juli und bin
jetzt eigentlich sehr zufrieden wie es
ob juli verlaufen ist ist es bei den
Schützen ist das ganz klar wenn man
einen Weltmeisterschaft hineingeht das
sind die Favoriten das ist die
abschlussstabelle die man von der man
ausgehen kann und alles andere
Überraschung oder ist wirklich jeder
Wettkampf dann hängt viel von der
tagesverfass abhängt viel ab von der
jeweiligen Form also gibt es da ganz
klare Ergebnisse von denen man ausgehen
kann oder ist jede jeder Wettkampf ein
neuer Wettkampf und alles ist viel
durchgemischt also es ist immer sehr
durchgemischt eigentlich aber man kann
schon mit einem gewissen
Leistungspotenzial eigentlich davon
ausgehen dass das Recht für ein Podium
oder für ein Finale der Top 8 da kann
man eigentlich so ganz gut kalkulieren
im 50 Meter und 300 m Bereich hängt
natürlich sehr viel wo die Bedingungen
für die äußeren Bedingungen ob da
irgendwas lustiges immer schwer
einschätzen wie viel braucht es dann
wirklich für Podium aber grundsätzlich
kann man ganz gut kalkulieren eigentlich
und wie war dein Gefühl als du die
Weltmeisterschaften gegangen bist hast
du gewusst ich mache da jetzt meine
Medaillen oder war das für dich auch
eine Überraschung also immer ehrlich
sagen ich war im Liegen Bewerb sehr sehr
gut drauf das hat dann so beim
Europakarte Finale begonnen habe
komplett neues Material rechtzeitig
testen können und das hat super
funktioniert und Network perfekt und bin
dort schon zweiter worden und dann habe
ich einfach gemerkt okay eigentlich bin
ich richtig gut in Formen der Disziplin
und hat man schon doch Richtung WM das
wird eher de Disziplin wo ich um die
Medaillen mitkämpfen kann das heißt das
Gefühl war auf jeden Fall da das jetzt
gesagt die Disziplin du machst nämlich
etwas was in vielen Sportarten oftmals
schwierig ist du schießt mit Großkaliber
Luftgewehr und Kleinkaliber und das eben
stehend und liegend das heißt drei
unterschiedliche Waffen mit
verschiedensten Körperpositionen wie
trainiert man das alles geht das
überhaupt so effektiv alles immer
versucht grundsätzlich die Gewehr
Einstellungen sehr sehr ähnlich zu
wählen damit man einfach der Umstieg für
die jeweiligen Disziplinen apokal
leichter wird aber wenn man technisch so
gemacht richtig ausgereift ist und die
Positionen richtig gut stimmen dann
lässt sie das eigentlich sehr
effizientieren oder allerdings braucht
es halt sehr viel Zeit immer alle
Positionen zu trainieren also da
verbringen sehr viel Zeit am Schießstand
das heißt du musst mehr trainieren als
andere die sich nur auf eine
Waffengattung und eine Position
spezialisieren habe ich das jetzt
richtig verstanden iOS Spezialist ist
ein bisschen einfacher vermutlich seine
eine Disziplin zu trainieren und als
Allrounder ist immer ein bisschen
zeitaufwendiger und intensiver alle
Positionen perfekt zu trainieren er
profitiert man dabei einer Waffengattung
von anderen von Training also wenn du
jetzt alles trainierst dass du sagst bei
dem profitiere ich davon dass ich das
andere auch Turniere weil mir das
bestimmte Elemente noch mit gibt deren
Spezialist nicht so oft trainiert gibt
es eigentlich gestehen bin immer gar
nicht so sicher ob das jetzt da immer so
positiv ist aber grundsätzlich die
letzte zielphase ist behaupte mal
überall sehr sehr ähnlich und das
perfekt abziehen das muss einfach immer
vor dem her glaube je mehr Schüsse immer
macht es sicher keine Nachteile
im 50 und im 300 mit der Bewerb hängt
auch von den äußerlichen Bedingungen ab
was kann man sich da darunter vorstellen
wenn man jetzt schießen nicht so
verfolgt sondern nur bei den Olympischen
Spielen einmal um alle vier Jahre im
Fernsehen sieht die Lichtverhältnisse
sind das sehr entscheidend das ist doch
eine sehr lange Distanz bei 300 Meter
wie die Sonneneinstrahlung ist wie die
Bodenverhältnisse sind wie hoch die
Scheiben vom Boden weg sind so Punkt du
Mera sehr viele Rolle der Wind ist
natürlich sehr sehr entscheidend muss
einfach dann taktisch klugscheißen um in
die richtigen windphasen in Schuss
abzugeben bzw genau wissen wie wirkt sie
der Wind auf meinen Schuss aus um es
Zentrum zu treffen gibt sowas wie im
Schwimmbad der Pool der liegt mir und da
bin ich gerne dort jedes Jahr dass ihr
sagt den Schießstand den mag ich gern
oder der den kann ich überhaupt nicht
aushalten gibt's so ähnliches noch ja
gibt es gibt tatsächlich schwierige
Schießstände wo es sehr sehr schwierig
ist in Wien zum Lesen etwas unfair ist
wo man sagt okay man kann nicht wirklich
kalkulieren warum und wieso die Schüsse
jetzt dort an wobei ist auch das ist und
dann richtig spannend dass an die Karten
neu gemischt und die macht halt dann ist
er nicht Spaß bei anderen Sportarten
weiß man dass es ganz ganz wichtig ist
im Training auch in die Prophylaxe zu
visieren das heißt dafür sorgen dass man
sich nicht verletzt gibt es bei euch so
klassische
schützenverletzungen
Schulterverletzungen kann ich mir gut
vorstellen oder oder andere Sachen wo du
gegen wirken musst damit das eben nicht
passiert also so richtig geil akute
Verletzungen haben wir eher selten was
bei uns eher auftritt sondern
Verschleißerscheinungen gerade so die
ganzen Gelenke
Rückenbereich Bandscheiben ist natürlich
einfach sehr sehr belastet durch die
einseitige Belastung immer wieder und
durch die unzähligen Trainingsstunden
die man in der sag mal nicht ganz
perfekten Körperposition verbringt da
ist einfach profilaktisch dort
vorzubeugen damit da keine
Abnutzungserscheinungen
in einer Körperposition jetzt nicht
unbedingt die natürlichste ist für den
Körper aber die haben optimalsten ist um
das Ziel am besten anzuschießen das
heißt da muss man sich wahrscheinlich
immer sich auch selbst gut kennen und
wissen was man braucht oder genau ja
also man versucht hat die Körperposition
zu finden wo das Gewehr einfach am
höchsten ähm voraus ist und das ist
nicht immer die körperschonendste
Position ja wenn du vorher angesprochen
hast dass du das Material gut abgestimmt
hast und neues Material bekommen dass
das gut gepasst hat das kann man sich
darunter vorstellen sind alle Waffen
gleich oder hat jeder individuell
angepasste Waffen was was gibt's dafür
für Spielraum beim Sport schießen also
eigentlich jeder
eine Waffe die perfekt auf sich selbst
abgestimmt ist da spürt natürlich sehr
viel Rolle also die auslöse Zeit vor der
Waffe später Rolle das Abzugsgewicht ist
sehr entscheidend wie passt es zu meinen
Schießstil und dann ist nur die Munition
es ist nicht jede Munition gleich also
es ist ein irrsinnliche Tüftelei um
wirklich dies perfekte munitionslos für
mein Gewehr zu finden dass das wirklich
absolut höchste Präzision bietet oder
ist es so dass wenn du sagst ich habe
jetzt für das Gewehr die Munition
gefunden und das schieße ich jetzt zehn
Jahre lang oder muss dann wirklich immer
anpassen für jeden Schießstand für den
Wettkampf für deine jeweilige Form ob du
schnellere Munition brauchst oder
langsam bzw genau wieder die die
Unterscheidungen sind also kann man sich
das so vorstellen ja das kann man sie
wirklich so vorstellen also so groß da
eher ein langsames munitionslos ist z.B
bei Wind von Vorteil schnellere Munition
auf bei reaktiven schützen und die
Temperatur später natürlich auch Rolle
ob es oft so wenn man dann ein perfektes
los gefunden hat dann ist es sehr oft so
dass man sein
Wettkampf gewähren mit der
wettkampfmunition mit der perfekten
Munition einfach schont und wirklich nur
die Wettkämpfe damit wirst und die
trainingsschüsse dann einfach am
trainingsgewer macht weil heute einfach
da im Jahr 40 50.000 Schuss drauf kommen
und das verändert natürlich auch wieder
es Gewehr und somit versucht man da
irgendwie dann wenn man so ein
wunderkombination hat die so lang wie
möglich einfach zu schonen ich gehe
davon aus du hast derzeit sein Wunder
Setup oder also sehr sehr gute Setup und
bin gerade am überlegen und am planen
wie das am besten so lange wie möglich
natürlich ausnutzen wie stark bist du
denn evolviert oder hast du über dem
Skifahren dann eigene Wechsel und eigene
munitionsexperten die dir zu spielen und
überlegen und Berechnungen machen oder
liegt das wirklich alles bei dir in der
Hand
also die letzte Entscheidung hoffentlich
immer der Schütze selbst wir Sandra sehr
gut aufgestellt zur Gemeinde haben da
unser
heereskadertrainer der Klaus desto
wirklich
extrem dahinter und versucht immer dass
wir das Beste vom Besten haben und
tüftel das sehr viel für uns das
natürlich sehr viel Zeit in Anspruch
nimmt und uns sage mal wertvolle
Trainingszeit wieder bringt man hat dann
schon sehr begeistert dafür die Technik
und versucht da sehr viel selbst nur zu
finden eigentlich das jetzt ähm Herr das
Kader Trainer angesprochen Sportschießen
ist eine militärische Schwerpunkt der
Sportart wie sehr profitiert man da auch
vom Know-how eines Bundesheers wie ähm
das unsere Geld das natürlich im
Schießen auch Expertise hat kann man
sich da gegenseitig befruchten immer
versuchten natürlich immer benefits für
jeder Seite zu holen und das macht
natürlich absolut Sinn so immer wieder
ein regen Austausch zum haben unter sie
werden zu entwickeln
für immer glaube ich machen wir da ganz
gute Wahrheit was würdest du sagen ist
deine Lieblingssaft und dann
lieblings-wettkampf also eigentlich ist
meine Lieblingsdisziplin ist 10 Meter
Luftgewehr allerdings bin in den letzten
Jahren im Dreistellungskampf eigentlich
viel besser waren und da ist natürlich
naheliegend dass sie das sehr sehr
bevorzuge aber so meine stille Liebe ist
eigentlich nur immer dass die mit der
Luftgewehr das heißt wenn du könntest
würdest du alles sein lassen und nur das
zehn Meter Luftgewehr schießen ja wobei
sagen ich bin in die anderen Disziplinen
mittlerweile viel besser vor dem her
würde man das noch genau überlegen mit
der Spezialisierung ja das heißt der
sportliche Erfolg da die Balance zum zum
Herzen genau 216 bei den Olympischen
Spielen in Rio dabei wie schaut's aus
Paris ist ja nicht mehr lange anderthalb
Jahre steht das am Programm und wie
schaut der Weg dort aus steht natürlich
ein Programm die ersten guten Plätze
sind es vergeben worden und da im
Frühjahr geht's dann weiter mit den
nächsten guten Plätzen und das nächste
Jahr steht natürlich ganz im Zeichen der
Qualifikation für die Olympischen Spiele
und bin gut gerüstet sag mir von
Material her gut aufgestellt und sehr
motiviert und möchte es auf jeden Fall
wieder schaffen bei den Olympischen
Spiele dabei was wird das brauchen
es wird eine sehr sehr gute Saison ob
Ende Jänner brauchen um einfach genügend
Punkte zum hohen um dann im Jahr darauf
in Paris am Start sein wie kann man sich
so eine Saison von euch vorstellen in
den meisten Sportarten hat man irgendwie
eine Aufbauphase und dann ist einmal
gemischt speziell Spezialisierung und
immer noch allgemein und dann geht's
wirklich in die in die höchste
Wettkampfform mit einem Großereignis ist
das bei euch auch so dass man das
wirklich jetzt gesehen kann oder gibt's
da jedes Wochenende irgendwann
Schießwettkampf und ihr müsst euch
überlegen wo baut sich hier die Form auf
und mehrere große eigenes im Jahr so wie
wie schaut das bei euch ganz genau aus
also früher war es ein bisschen
einfacher zum periodisieren das ist Sohn
da war einfach im März der Höhepunkt der
10 Meter Saison dann hat drei vier
Monate geben und Ende August war dann
die 50 Meter
Höhepunkt
und jetzt ist es eigentlich so jetzt die
Weltmeisterschaft war Ende Oktober und
den drei Wochen gingen die ersten zehn
Meter Qualifikationen los also wir
schießen mittlerweile
und man muss halt danach auch für sich
selbst dafür entscheiden okay auf welche
große Ereignisse lege jetzt gezielt wird
weil es hat sehr schwierig wo Jänner bis
November in perfekter Form zu sein aber
wir versuchen das sehr gut zum Planen
und der Blut zum abwechseln dass das für
alle sehr gut funktioniert wie siehst du
die Entwicklung im internationalen
Skisport wenn du sagst dass es jetzt
mehr Wettkämpfe gibt und man sich selber
aussuchen kann wo man die Form sozusagen
hin trainiert nimmt das an Qualität raus
oder sagt das dafür dass man einfach
immer irgendetwas zu bieten hat im
Schießsport also ich persönlich glaube
es nimmt die Qualität raus die neue
Saison ist einfach sehr sehr
kostenintensiv für alle Verbände mit so
viel Großveranstaltung und so verwirk
gehabt jetzt da versucht man natürlich
Höhepunkte zu setzen und die Besetzung
bei jeweiligen Welt gehabt wird dann
immer fraglich sei erst einmal am Start
steht wird man tatsächlich wissen seine
130 Starter oder oder doch nur 70 das
wird sehr sehr interessant sein weil es
heute damit die Weltcup Punkte
zusammenhängt und macht es noch
schwieriger finde ich da wirklich gut
und konsequent zu planen wie viele
Waffen sind in deinem Besitz
das ist jetzt eine gute Frage wieso die
fast überlegen aber ich denke es an so
sieben acht Gewehre die da haben sie ich
habe dann immer eigentlich ein
wettkampfgewehr ein trainingsgewehr und
meistens nur ein reservegewehr und das
brotdisziplin um auf Nummer sicher zu
gehen dass der Junge sein kann und das
summiert sich dann über die Jahre etwas
lernen und wie lange kann man sein
Gewehr schießen da muss man jedes
Personen ein neues Gewehr haben oder hat
man das als ewigen Begleiter seine ganze
Karriere durch also meine zehn Meter
Gewehre die habe es ewige Begleiter da
ist kaum Abnutzung und die Qualität
super die halten ewig beim 50 und 300
Meter Bereich braucht man gelegentlich
um einen neuen Lauf aber die
Hauptbestandteile bleiben meist
dieselben eigentlich und wie kann man
sich das kostente praktisch verstehen
ist natürlich bei euch das viele
Reisenden Thema aber auch Munition kann
mir vorstellen dass es nicht günstig ist
und eben auch Ersatzteile für Gewerbe
also wo liegt das so der Preis seines
guten
sportschützengewehres also so die
Topmodelle im Teambereich sind sie
1000 Euro und im 50 und 300 Meter
Bereich liegen wir irgendwo komplett für
Setup bei 10000 € vermutlich heute dafür
sehr lange oder super Qualität die
Munition macht oft sehr teuer also ohne
gute Partner ist man da schnell einmal
im sehr sehr hochstelligen Bereich immer
da investieren muss und ich nehme alles
auf die Munition jetzt nicht bei dir
daheim herumliegt sondern dass du die
beim beim Schießstand hast beim
Trainingszentrum wie wird das
gehandhabt und und logistisch gelöst
nein in Österreich ist erlaubt dass ihr
Mann safe unter der Munition und lockert
werden und dann habe ich ansehen wo die
der trainingsmunition gut gelagert ist
also da ist man in Österreich eigentlich
sehr gut aufgestellt im Sportschützen
gegenüber wie bist du zum Schießen
gekommen durch meinen Vater und meine
Schwester also meine Schwester war schon
österreichischer Meisterin da in ihrer
Jugend und da war es zwangsläufig bin
immer weil wieder am Schießstand
mitgegangen und habe bei Tennis gespielt
Fußball gespielt und alles mögliche und
habe dann irgendwann in mit 16 17 die
Entscheidung treffen diesen Skisport
intensiver zu probieren und dann bin ich
eigentlich drauf gekommen also das ist
ganz gut im Griff habe den Sport und er
kann sein talentiert bin und dann habe
ich eigentlich so durchgezogen ja gibt's
bei euch auch irgendwie ein Scouting
System man sagt der ist ein ganz
besonderes ruhiger der wird gut zum
Schießen passen oder kann man das gar
nicht so sagen bevor man nicht die Waffe
in Hand hat und auf das Ziel schießt
ich glaube man muss es wirklich am
Schießstand erkennen wie einer voraus
aus den Umgang mit dem Sport Gewehr hat
wie wird das an die ganze Sache
herangeht dass ich mal so mal am besten
aber ich glaube es gibt schon so eher
die ruhigen entspannten Typen sind denke
ich voraus aus so ganz gut für diesen
Sport dass wir die billigen das
vermutlich nicht das optimalste ja
würdest du sagen wenn jemand ein
Ausgleichsport braucht oder vielleicht
dazu im Alltag meinen Ausgleich sucht
dass man da auch hobbymäßig schießen
probieren sollte aber ich glaube dass
der Skisport ganz interessant ist äh
Körper und Geist muss da einfach
wirklich am Punkt Dose und es ist glaube
ich richtig gut zum Abschalten und so in
seine eigene Welt zum Eintreten darum
glaube das ist ja ganz gut oder
Ausgleich ist im Alltag man weiß ja vom
Biathlon deswegen die Athleten aus
höchster Belastung dann zum Schießstand
kommen und den ersten Schuss daneben
setzen das ist auch mental wahnsinnig
schwierig ist man kann wahrscheinlich
ein super Schütze sein
wenn man dann mit sich selbst irgendwie
nicht funktioniert in dem Moment dann
kommt der Frust auf ist das vielleicht
auch so dass es ein mentales Spiel auch
ist dass man Frust Toleranz haben muss
dass man sofort abhacken muss zum
nächsten Schuss ansetzen muss also ist
das ein wichtiges Element bei euch auch
ja absolut also der Kopf der muss
einfach wirklich da sein
KörperGeist ist müssen in der Hand gehen
das muss perfekt funktionieren
das ist so in Bruchteil einer Sekunde
passiert so viel beim Zielen äh du musst
einfach wirklich immer weißt du sein und
da kann man null Ablenkung gebrauchen
und ja wann der Schuss geschossen ist
dann ist er schon vorbei dann hilft
nichts ist aber schwieriger Prozess dass
man da wirklich sehr sehr kontrolliert
an der Sache herangeht und das sagt sich
immer leichter als das dann in dem
Moment ist dass man sagt es ist schon
vorbei und ich kann nichts verändern auf
den nächsten konzentrieren weil
wahrscheinlich mit sich selber der
strengste Kritiker ist jetzt ist der der
Torschützen Sport vor allem während der
Olympischen Spielen mit viel
Aufmerksamkeit
gesegnet sei jetzt einmal dazwischen hat
man das Gefühl dass wenn ihr natürlich
Erfolge habt dass das auch dann gut
berichtet wird er was würde es noch
brauchen damit der Schützensport
durchgängig in den Medien ist aber auch
in aller Munde also ich glaube dass du
der internationalen Verband sehr gefragt
ist einfach um und die Übertragung zu
modernisieren um das wirklich leicht
verständlicher zu machen wir haben oft
eigenartige Regeländerungen ihnen selbst
in den vier Jahreszyklus wo wir Athleten
selbst eine ganz verstehen warum und
wieso müssen wir jetzt den Sport zu
verändern und ich glaube dann oder
internationale verbannt wirklich sagt
okay diese Richtung gehen wir dann ist
glaube ich sehr sehr einfach in Zukunft
den Sport da gut zu vermarkten damit er
wieder einfach wird zum Verstehen für
die Zuschauer und dann denke ich ist es
ähm ja wird sicher eine schöne Zukunft
haben man sieht äh du beschäftigst dich
viel mit einem Sport und hast doch dazu
sehr gute Gedanken jetzt zum Abschluss
noch ein paar kurze Fragen an dich an
meinem Sport begeistert mich am meisten
also das Zusammenspiel vom Körper und
Geist so in der letzten Sekunde
formschuss ist für mich so die
Begeisterung in dem Sport wenn ich nicht
Sportler wäre dann wäre ich
vermutlich irgendwo in einer fanmechanik
Branche wenn man das ist nicht
fasziniert ja und das heißt diese
Tendenz zum zum zur feinen Hand zu
ruhigen Hand die hättest du auch dort er
vermutlich ja nee meine stärkste
Eigenschaft ist ich denke meine Humor
und mein Gelassenheit das kann ich nur
unterstreichen ich kann dich also seit
vielen Jahren im Herzen Zentrum meine
schwächste Eigenschaft ist sicher meine
Emotionalität noch
schlechten Situationen ja aber nicht im
Wettkampf selbst oder mittlerweile immer
ja also durch ich träume von einer
olympischen Medaille eigentlich ja wie
würdest du da die Chancen einschätzen
sicher schwierig aber machbar Alexander
vielen vielen Dank für deine Zeit beim
Sportverbot und wir wünschen Dir
natürlich alles Gute danke danke
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal dabei seid bis dann
[Applaus]